fatigué fatigué je peux capable de
recommencer une école pas capable de
recommencer le travail marché parts ou
mal de tête
j'aime à la tête jour et nuit
bisous et le coronavirus le printemps
dernier et ont encore d'importantes
séquelles cinq six sept mois plus tard
denis suzy ont été déclarés positifs à
la coved le 23 mars après neuf jours de
fièvre intense
denis a été hospitalisé aux soins
intensifs capable
puis à pleins doutes pour jour parce
qu'ils me l'ont demandé si tu fais un
arrêt cardiaque est ce qu'on peut pas
partir oui deux jours après les émeutes
élément passe en premier par suzy qui a
51 ans est frappée moins durement par le
virus mais les séquelles ne lui laisse
aucun répit crise d'épilepsie anomalie
cardiaque et des migraines en permanence
et fois ça me réveille la nuit ça
m'empêche adorent mais je me rendors pas
parce que 180 g mais malgré cette
douleur chronique
la secrétaire médicale est de retour au
travail depuis juin denis qui a 60 ans a
recommencé à travailler mais il ya
seulement trois semaines ils ne
travaillent que deux jours par semaine
et peine à finir ses journées moi c'est
surtout les jeunes aux articulations
j'ai encore des raccords malin des
mollets je veux monter les marches
audrey grand chose là j'ai couru vain
que la matière certains vont être
essoufflé à l'effort le guide est à
idées je marche un peu beaucoup même au
point que certains ne peuvent pas
retourner à leur travail de base c'est
un travail physique là selon l'internet
les douleurs musculaires le denis assez
commune chez les malades hospitalisés
sont en partie dus aux des cadrans une
anti inflammatoire plus puissant que la
cortisone les bons dans le traitement de
l'aco vide
il sauve des vies sans cet autre positif
mais il est terrible sur la force
musculaire la possibilité d'avoir une
faiblesse permanente existe elle est
tout à fait l'homme
julie dolan qui est infirmière
auxiliaire a été diagnostiqué à la fin
avril
six mois plus tard elle était encore à
bout de souffle
je trouve que c'est pire qu'après que
pendant pourquoi vu que ça perdure
tellement longtemps qu'ils convient
puiser c'est comme manquer d'air
dimon qui durera deux semaines c'est ça
va passer mais c'est manqué d'être tout
le temps c'est sûr longue haleine
c'est c'est plus dur comme bien d'autres
malades de la queue vide
julie a des pertes de mémoire de la
difficulté à se concentrer et a subi une
importante baisse de vision faut que
j'aille refaire un examen de la vue
place que je dois forcer mes yeux avec
minutes on a une à peine possible la
rétine une séquelle tout à fait
plausible selon le docteur marc hic la
commune dispersent dans le sens des mini
caillou qui bloque de petits vaisseaux
sanguins
cela peut aussi provoquer des migraines
des troubles cardiaques et des crises
d'épilepsie comme la rétine les neurones
du cerveau ont énormément besoin
d'oxygène ccc des cellules sont
monstrueuses mac gourmande en oxygène et
si on leur baisse le roxy jeunes
elle ne meurt pas tout de suite elle
fonctionne normalement
et voici le lien potentiel avec
l'épilepsie
durant la phase aiguë de la maladie
beaucoup perdent l'odorat certains le
récupère complètement d'autres retrouve
un sens dysfonctionnelle tout ce qu'ils
sentent à une odeur nauséabonde
ça semble de plus notre noisy-le
maintenant expiré depuis des années qui
est 40 couches de jeu le champignon tout
- est-ce que ça me donne la nausée ouais
c'est automatique j'ai tout de suite mal
aux cas je m'éloigne elle se sépare
répugnant c'est infirmière de 23 ans a
été contaminé en mai dernier cinq mois
plus tard elle n'est toujours pas de
retour au travail
elle est encore trop essoufflé et
fatigué et moi je fais mes affaires je
roule je peux rouler a semblé avoir le
dans mes projets je suis motivé je pense
mais là c'était vraiment dur de me
retrouver
je pouvais plus avancer comme avant
c'est parce que le cheminement difficile
c'est aussi peu au secours savent eux
aussi peu que ça va finir on s'y perd
rien du gouvernement de suède ont fait
son retour
on va passer outre avoir l'immunité qu
alex fava est le désastre pour cet
hyperactif c'est très pénible de ne plus
pouvoir bouger ou travailler comme avant
denis souffre de voir des amis douter de
la gravité du virus et plaidé pour
l'abandon des mesures sanitaires
aujourd'hui souvent site france à
l'économie parce que totale de travail
de quelque chose sera même capable dans
un style punk se remet plus capable en
tire les tabliers et ce pas nul du tiers
des malades de la coved aurait dit si
qu'elle il faudra quelques années avant
de connaître l'ampleur des dommages
permanents